new lava fissures in Hawaii could force
another 2,000 people to evacuate their
homes that's on top of the more than
1,700 people who've already left there
are 18 fissures near the Kilauea volcano
another may major highway is at risk
David beg no is at a road closure in
Pahoa Hawaii David good morning good
morning it's incredible we're hearing
what sounds like a fireworks show right
now our thunder directly behind us but
it's lava shooting up through one of
these fissures which is a crack in the
earth from what I can see there's an
orange glow on the horizon and the
concern now is new fissures will force
the closure of a second evacuation route
I mean these fissures are popping up
almost daily that's the sound of the
impending danger for more residents of
the Big Island of Hawaii at a thousand
feet long this fissure is one of two
that broke through the ground on Sunday
spewing lava and toxic sulfur dioxide
gas into the air
self-proclaimed lava chaser Demi and
Barrios apparently ignored strict
evacuation orders to livestream this
video from a neighbor's back porch
Sunday it shows large chunks of molten
rock so-called lava bombs shooting into
the air some of which actually landed in
the backyard
the latest eruptions are on the east end
of the line of fissures pointing
directly to highway 130 - if officials
have to close that highway as many as
2,000 people living in coastal
communities below leilani estates in
lower Puna are gonna have a hard time
getting out quickly here at the Pahoa
roadblock residents have taken it upon
themselves to feed each other
providing hot meals and supplies Miley
Orion Collins forced out of her home
more than a week ago is volunteering to
help people in need as she waits we live
here because we love it and we know that
and part of the life is that we live on
an active volcano and there's any data
lakyn Chaney Joe masoorie and Colin says
around her home the air is so bad it's
nearly impossible to breathe now there
is the possibility of a steam fueled
explosion of the volcano which could
produce boulders the size of
refrigerators but they wouldn't fall
near populated areas and ash would be
the real concern as to when that could
happen nobody really knows all right
David the video looks like something out
of a movie thank you so much